a lot of your fans
Like about the documentaries are your voiceovers you do those voiceover?
It's kind of explaining what you were feeling at the time, you know, I felt so and so was tiring of my questions
So I decided to leave
Do you know what I'm talking about?
Yeah. Well, what about what about the voiceovers though you well, you know, you know what I'm talking about that that thing that you do
I've got confused by Graham's question. It occurred to me that perhaps he was trying to lure me into one of his comedy bits
An attempt to disarm him I decided to say nothing
Louis' silence caught me off guard. I decided to play it cool and drink some wine
This was getting awkward. Was Graham simply embarrassed, or was it true he does have a drinking problem?
I wondered if my fellow guests felt as uncomfortable as I did?
I shared Louis' discomfort. Graham seemed distracted and it was a long time since he'd asked me a question about my book
Why is everyone talking to themselves?
Jeez they're really flogging this comedy bit. When is Graham going to introduce me?